our big story this morning is hurricane
Florence forecasters watching the
hurricane are warning it could cause
terrible damage and loss of life over a
huge area of the US the National Weather
Service describes it as quote the storm
of a lifetime
top sustained winds this morning are 130
miles an hour it is expected to
strengthen before it hits the Carolinas
in about 48 hours as many as 25 million
people are in Florence's projected path
we don't know where this massive storm
will go after it hits the coast the
worst possibility is it could stall
meteorologist Megan Glaros of our
Chicago station wbbm-tv is here with the
newest changes to Florence's track Megan
good morning good morning John and there
have been some changes and probably not
for the better what we're looking at
right now is still a category 4 storm
this is a force of nature winds to 130
as you said moving west-northwest at 17
what's happening is it's rolling over
warmer waters in the Atlantic right now
that's serving to really strengthen it
landfall looks still to be sometime
early Friday but the question is where
and does it stay off the coastline for
longer that would actually be a worse
scenarios and move forward here because
if it rides off the coastline that means
you're getting the storm surge
continuing the winds continuing the rain
for a longer time period it continues to
ride down that coast and obviously then
you're also talking about a bigger area
that it could be impacting of most
strongly now we've got a ridge of high
pressure on off near Bermuda another up
across parts of the United States the
problem is they're kind of combining and
so it's not giving the storm anywhere to
go it's trapped essentially and that's
going to push it south a little bit
that's why we've seen those changes to
the model guidance and the changes to
the track what we're looking at here
though is always on the right side of
circulation specifically the right front
quadrant that's where we have the
greatest concern for storm surge for
winds and for tornadoes within the
landfalling hurricane we're also talking
about a major rainfall event upwards of
30 inches possible and that area as well
has expanded so certainly something that
bears watching over these next few days
go well none of it looks or sounds good
thank you very much Megan